Now let's talk about implementation of the capsule,
and in particular what are the actions taken on
capsule arrival at a particular node. Now, I mentioned
that the capsule does not contain code, but it
is passed by reference. Or in other words
what the capsule contains is the type identify which
is really a fingerprint for the capsule code. And
the way this type is generated it's basically a
cryptographic fingerprint of the original capsule code.
In the original implementation of Ann's tool
kit they used an MD5 hash of the code and used that as a fingerprint.
And it was the case that at the time that this particular research was
done, MD5 hash was a cryptographically strong
hash function, which was not broken. But subsequently
MD5 hash has been broken. But nevertheless, the key
thing that I want you to remember is that
this type field is a cryptographically strong fingerprint that
is derived from the capsule code. And that serves as
a reference for the code itself. So when a
node receives a capsule, one of two things are possible.
The first possibility is that this node has seen
capsules of this type before. If that is the case,
then it is quite likely that in the soft
store of this node the code that corresponds to
this type is already existing. In which case, it's
a simple thing for the current node to retrieve the
code from its soft store, and execute the capsule
and proceed with forwarding this capsule on to where its
desired destination. On the other hand, if this capsule
that arrived at this node is the first time that
this node is seeing a capsule of this type, then, obviously,
it's not going to have the code that corresponds to this
type. In this case, what this current node is going to
do is use the previous node field of the capsule and
send a request to the previous node saying that, hey I
got this capsule of this type, I don't have the code.
Do you have the code? If you have, please send it
to me. And when this request comes in, the previous node,
obviously it has processed this capsule before. It's quite likely
that this previous node has the capsule code residing in
its soft store. And so it retrieves it from its
soft store and sends it to the next node so
that the next node has the capsule code now, can
execute it, and also store it now locally in its
own soft store so that future capsules of the same
type when they arrive here, it can be processed using
the code that is now stored in the soft store. And
the key point to take away is that typically when we
are talking about network flows, we are sending a whole bunch
of packets one after another. And therefore, even though the first
packet that comes to a node may not find the code
that is associated with that particular type, and we have to
do a little bit of heavy lifting in, in terms of
going and reaching back to the previous node to retrieve the code.
Because network flow is a whole bunch of packets, there's
going to be a whole lot of other packets that
come down the pike. They're all going to be processed
using the soft store and the code that is stored in
the soft store. In other words, we are exploiting the
locality for capsule processing by storing the code that arrives in
response to our request back to a previous node in
the local soft store. One concern that we may have is
that how do I believe that the code that I
got from the previous node is actually the code that corresponds
to this type or not. Well, this is where the
cryptograpically strong fingerprint comes into play. What this node is going
to do is, when it retrieves the code from the
previous node, and when the code arrives, it is going to
compute the fingerprint of the code that it just got. And
see if that fingerprint matches the type field of the capsule.
If it does, then it knows that this code
is genuine. If it is not, then obviously somebody is
trying to spoof my node by giving bogus codes
so I'm going to reject it. So code spoofing can
be avoided by having a fingerprint that is cryptographically
strong, so that I can recompute the fingerprint match it
against the type, and know that the demand loaded code
that I got is actually the code that is associated
with this particular capsule. And as I mentioned already, once
I get this code, because I'm going to most likely
see capsules of this type in the future as part
of this particular network flow, I'm going to save the code
in the soft store for future use. So when a
capsule arrives at a node one of two things will
happen. One is I will reach into my soft store
and see if I have the code that matches this particular
type in the capsule. If it isn't then I don't
have the code, I'm going to reach back and get it
from the previous node. But what if I go back
to the previous node and the previous node does not have
the code that corresponds to this type. So the action
of a node when it cannot find the code that corresponds
to a type either locally in its soft store or retrieving
it from the previous node, is to simply drop the capsule.
Because what's going to happen is that if this capsule
is dropped, higher-level acknowledgements that
are happening in that particular network
flow is going to indicate to the source that something
did not get through, and that source node is going to retransmit
that capsule. This is exactly the same thing that happens
with IP routing on the Internet. That is, if a node
cannot process all the packet that it gets, it simply
drops the packet. That's the same semantic that is used for
capsule processing also because we're relying on higher level
protocols, the transfer protocol that sits on top of
the network protocol do end to end acknowledgement to
make sure that all the packets that they're expecting
have actually reached. And therefore at the level of
capsule processing, we don't have to worry if we
cannot process the capsule either locally by using the
code in the soft store or by retrieving the code
from the previous node. Simply drop the capsule. Now, is
it likely that, when we reach into the previous node, that
node does not have the code for it? Because, after
all, it did process this capsule, and send this capsule on
to me. It can happen, because the soft store is
limited. Every router node has only a finite capacity, and all
of its capacity it's not going to give to a
single network flow. It's going to give only a part of
its storage for the network flow that is
corresponding to a particular capsule type. And therefore, I
have to live within my means. So, the capsule
code may have to throw away stuff every once
in a while if it is storing more than what its capacity is in the soft store.
So it is possible that the code that it
originally stored in the soft store, it had to
replace it. Because it is like a cache and therefore, it
may have replaced it and therefore, it may not have it.
And this is particularly possible if this request comes at a
much later time because one of the things that you associate
with this kind of routing code is that it is going
to be timely. So there is going to be a time
associated with the validity of things that I want to keep
in my soft store. So if I, I get a request
at this node at a much later point in time because the capsule arrived at this
node traversing all over the network, it may
not have the code that corresponds to the
type. So it is possible, so if it happens, simply drop the capsule and let the
higher level entities in the protocol stack take
care of retransmitting the capsule if need be.